All right.
So good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for joining us in
this exciting award session.
So,
my name is Ruth Shechtman. I'm a professor at the Weizmann
Institute,
where I study the tumor microenvironment.
But today, I'm here as a presenter of
today's award. So it's a true honor and pleasure to present the
AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in Basic Cancer
Research. This special award recognizes early career
investigators under the age of 46, whose
outstanding scientific achievements, creativity, and innovation are
shaping the future of basic cancer research.
And this year's honoree exemplifies these qualities through
extraordinary contributions to cancer epigenetics and RNA
biology. Dr. He is an
experimental and computational biologist at Princess
Margaret Cancer Center and professor at the Department of
Medical Biophysics at the University of Toronto.
He's widely recognized for seminal discoveries in chromatin
dynamics, non-coding RNAs, and epigenetic vulnerabilities
in cancer.
Dr. He obtained his PhD in molecular biology and
bioinformatics at the Institute of Biophysics, Chinese Academy of
Science in 2008. He then trained as a
postdoc fellow at the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and
Harvard University, and I know his mentors are here and very
proud. During this time, he helped
pioneer approaches to map chromatin dynamics and predict
transcription factor binding, work that fundamentally advanced
how we interpret regulatory DNA. In his own lab, a
major focus of Dr. He's work has been the role of non-coding
RNAs in cancer. His group provided the first genome-wide
evidence that prostate cancer risk variants are
predominantly located in cis-regulatory elements, and that
long non-coding RNAs play major roles in prostate cancer
predisposition.
Dr. He has also made seminal contributions to the study of
circular RNAs. His group generated the first comprehensive transcriptional and
functional landscape of circular RNAs in patient tumors,
identified thousands with functional roles in cancer, and
opening an entirely new dimension of tumor biology.
More recently, his work has revealed how circular RNAs contribute to
tumor transdifferentiation, including the emergence of
neuroendocrine in small cell states.
In parallel, Dr. He's research has uncovered important mechanisms of
epigenetic regulation. His group made key discoveries on the
histone demethylase LSD1, including its role in
epigenetic reprogramming and therapeutic resistance, and
revealed a novel strategy to target and pioneer transcription factor
FOXA1 indirectly in cancer.
More recently, he has advanced the field in cancer
epitranscriptomics through pioneering studies in
m6A RNA methylation, identifying patterns
associated with metastasis, tumor progression, and poor clinical
outcomes, and establishing m6A signatures as promising
biomarkers and therapeutic targets.
Dr. He has published over 140 articles with more than
17,000 citations, and his discoveries are already
advancing towards clinical translation, including an ongoing Phase
2 trial evaluating RNA-based therapeutics in prostate
cancer.
His contributions have been recognized by numerous prestigious awards,
of which I'll only mention the Terry Fox New Investigator Award
and the Bernard and Francine Dorval Prize.
Overall, Dr. He's work has reshaped our understanding
of non-coding RNA biology and epigenetic regulation in
cancer, with impact spanning from fundamental discovery
to clinical application. So please join me in
congratulating and
welcoming Dr. He, the 2026 recipient of the AACR
Award for Outstanding Achievement in Basic Cancer Research, and I'm looking
forward to hearing about your work. Congratulations.
Okay. Good afternoon. Thank you, Ruthie, for the very
kind remarks.
So I'm
really honored and humbled to receive this prestigious
award,
which recognizes and celebrates the power of basic
discoveries to transform cancer medicine.
I'm grateful to the AACR, the
award committee, and then the nominators, which I
only find out very recently.
So today, I'll
share with you some of our recent work in
RNA biology and its impact and the
potential translation in
cancer therapy. And before that is my short
disclosure. So I did my PhD training
with Dr. Yun-Shin Chen at Chinese Academy of Sciences,
focusing on non-coding RNA in a model organism
named C. elegans. And I did my postdoc training with
Miles Brown and Shirley Liu, who are in the audience,
from Dana-Farber, focused on cancer epigenetics and
study how chromatin dynamics impact
transcription regulation in prostate cancer and breast cancer.
And this big shift of study
organism from a C. elegans to human
and from non-coding RNA to cancer epigenetics actually
provide me a very unique lens
through which I approach
cancer research. So I'll draw your attention to a
few
fun facts and numbers
to compare C. elegans and human. So C.
elegans is aVery little worm, with
about 1 millimeter size and has
959 cells. And we're human, we have 37
trillion cells. And C. elegans live a life of two to three weeks.
Under certain condition, can live quite a longer time.
And human, 70 to 80 years, maybe 100 years
soon.
The genome size of C. elegans are very small, only 100
megabyte, or human, 3 point gigabyte.
And if you look at the protein-coding genes, surprisingly similar,
20,000 protein-coding genes. Right?
So if you compare the biologic
complexity between C. elegans and human, you wouldn't
imagine by the same 20,000 protein-coding
genes can make such a dramatic change.
So what's the difference? If you look at the other part of our human
genome,
in human, there are about three to four times more,
small non-coding RNA,
about five to seven times more long non-coding RNA, and
about 100 times more of circRNA, and more
than 100 times of regulatory regions. Right?
So I think it's reasonable to hypothesize
that this big biological complexities in
human,
is largely driven by the complex
regulatory mechanisms governed by non-coding RNA,
non-coding regulatory elements that control the
temporal and the spatial
regulation of gene expression and contribute to this
huge expansion of biological complexity.
And in the context of cancer, I would borrow the concept
from risk management, which is complexity is
vulnerability. So cancer leverages those
expanded regulatory mechanisms to develop
and to survive. And this shaped the research in
my group. So I've been largely focused on understanding
how the non-coding RNAs and non-coding
regulatory elements and then the post-transcripitonal
modification of RNA,
and the epigenetic mechanism, of course, to regulate the
cancer-specific vulnerabilities.
So we largely took
patient tumor profiling approaches, coupled with functional
genomic screening and integrative analysis based-- I
benefited from my training with Shirley.
And with the goal to identify mechanisms that
underlie epigenetic and RNA
regulation of gene expression and identify cancer-specific
vulnerabilities, and then recently been
spending quite a lot efforts in developing RNA-based
therapeutics. So today I'm going to share with you one particular
area, which is circRNA, which fascinated me most.
So circRNA is formed through a unique
mechanism called the back splicing.
So through this mechanism is form a covalent close the circle.
It's actually been identified very early in the 1970s.
But the field
got started in 2013,
through two nature papers,
and published it at the same time, reporting through high-throughput
sequencing,
identified a couple of thousand of circRNAs in mouse and the
human genome, and
both study identify circR7
as a very important function of circRNA
in human and mouse. So nowadays we know that circRNA are
functional. So in the nucleus, they can bind to the DNA
and then involved in transcription regulation.
Outside the nucleus, its most well-known function is
microRNA sponge. So for example, circR7 binds to more than
70 miR-7, or have more than 70 miR-7 binding
sites. So it's a function of the sponge for miR-7.
And in some cases, interact with proteins, function as protein
sponge, and in other cases, helping protein to form a
structure, functioning as a protein scaffold.
In some rare cases, they also translate and
form a small peptide, which I will touch on that at
the end of the talk. So in 2016, when I started
to look into the circRNA, there's not much on
circRNA study in cancer and in particular in
patient tumor. So I basically asked the three questions.
How many circRNAs are expressed in patient tumor?
And are circRNA even important in tumor biology?
And if they're important, how do they function?
And the last is that whether circRNA are clinically
useful.
So to answer the first question, whether circRNA are
expressed in tumor. So we took a sequencing-based approach
because circRNA, they don't have poly-A tail, so we have to use the
total RNA sequencing. And then the way to identify circRNA is quite
straightforward. So we're looking for the
back-splicing junction reads, chimeric reads, that maps
at the back-splice site. So those are specific
when they form a circle, and you won't find it if they don't form the
circle.
Okay, so in about 200 prostate cancer patient
tumors from two patient cohorts, one from Canada, one from
Netherlands. So we identified 80,000
circRNAs. And with each tumor,
on average, we can identify about 7,000 circRNAs being
detected. And then,
at the same time,
Eruchin Ayyan's group from Michigan, they used different
approaches and the exome capturing approaches, and they analyzed about 2,000
patient tumors and cell lines, and they identified
160,000 circRNA. And since then,
a lot of more function profiling andOn our
patient tumor profiling work has been conducted, and the number has kept
going up. And then
the latest update, and the number has gone up to
400,000 circRNAs in the human genome.
So the first thing we noticed through those patient tumor
profiling is that circRNA are very cancer and cell
type specific, as you'll see here.
And another thing is that circRNA, so they're usually not very
abundant because the back splicing mechanism is not a very
efficient splicing mechanism. So in majority of the
cases, when the gene got transcribed, you will see the linear
form, and then the circular form is usually less than
5% compared to their linear form. But we do find that
in about 3%
of the cases
in the circRNA, that they predominantly exist
in the circular form. I'll show you an example later
on. So we identified tens of
thousands of circRNAs, so are they even important?
So we started from a small functional screening
and then now expanded to a larger functional screening.
And then selected from the patient tumor profilings and then
selected about 10,000 circRNA and designed an shRNA library to
target both the circular RNA at the junction
site and their linear parental genes.
And then we performed a functional screening in seven cancer types,
and then the results are quite
interesting. So in total, we identified about
1,300 of the circRNAs out of the
10,000 circRNA we
screened for,
are essential or important in at least one of the
cancer cell lines that we have screened for.
And more than 90% of those, their function has never been
reported before. And most of these
functionality actually are quite cancer type specific.
Actually, in about 43% of those cases, they're only
functional in one particular cancer type.
And for example, in this case, particular circRNAs are only essential
in prostate cancer, but not in any other of the cancer types.
And in 95% or over 95% of those
cases, when the circRNA is important, their linear gene
is not important. So this functionality is very
specific to the
circular form.
So building on those profiling and the functional
screening, we created this database called FuncCirc,
functional circRNA.
So this,
we assembled
clinical gene expression in over
26,000 patient tumors, and we're in the process of adding
another 5,000 patient tumors.
And then we collected public screening data and together with
ours, functional screening in about 28
unique cancer types for functional
investigation of circRNA.
So we hope that this database will be very
useful to the community. And based on this
database, we actually built an AI agent.
We named it CircularNavigate, so navigator.
So it's currently being tested internally, and we hope to release
it in the next month or two. So this is actually a
specialized AI agent that had the
domain knowledge on circRNA and it had access
to the databases that we generated and
then leveraged the external
and other AI agents that help us to
analyze and to design experiment for
circRNA studies. So we hope those tools will
be useful
to the field. So how do the
circRNA function? So I'll show you one example.
So
at the plenary session yesterday,
Charles Sawyers
talked about the neuroendocrine differentiation from prostate
cancers. In prostate cancer, more than 98% of the
tumors started as adenocarcinoma.
And then if you keep pushing with the AR pathway inhibitors, and
then
about 15% to 20% of the patients
will have their tumor
lineage shifted from adenocarcinoma to neuroendocrine prostate cancer,
in many cases, small cell
neuroendocrine tumor. So we did circRNA profiling in the
adenocarcinoma and in the small cell neuroendocrine tumor.
So the first thing we noticed that in the red color, that the
circRNA global abundance in the
neuroendocrine or small cell prostate cancer are much higher than the
adenocarcinoma. And then we identify a very clear
outlier, a circRNA called the CIRC-MST, that
is very specifically expressed in neuroendocrine prostate
cancer. And you can barely detect them in the
adenocarcinoma. And this expression is
also high in small cell lung cancer, in particular, the
ASL1 subtype, the A subtype, driven
by transcription factor
ASL1. So we know that clinically and also
molecularly, that the neuroendocrine small cell prostate cancer
are very similar to
small cell lung cancer. So it's not surprising to see some
common effect here. So this circRNA is very
interesting. As I mentioned, the circRNA,
the back splicing
mechanism is not very efficient. In most of the cases, you'll see
the circular form isless expressive than
the linear form. But in this case,
RMST is exon three and 10 form a circular RNA, and then
its mature RNA, you pretty much only see the
signal from the RNC, the exon
three and 10. And later on, we also confirm that
this circular RNA, they pretty much don't have a mature linear
transcript. You will see some signal that are unspliced
or pre-RNA. But linear genes, they pretty much almost
100% exist in a circular form. So why is that?
Okay. So circular RNA, they're actually
very conserved between human and mice.
So in this particular case, circRMST,
so that the exons that form a circRNA are exactly the same.
And then the only difference is the last exon in human, we don't see
any signal. In mouse, we see some signal.
We don't know what it does, whether it's functional.
But in both human and mice in the
mouse model of neuroendocrine prostate cancer, we also see that
the circRMST expression is extremely high.
And in both human and mouse, in their intron,
flanking the exons that form a circRNA,
we can find a repeat region called
MirB. So they exist
in opposite directions, like this part
exists in the
negative direction, and then this is in the positive direction.
And what those repeat does is that because they are transcribed in
reversed direction, they can actually form a perfectly
base
pairing. And those base pairing in the flanking introns can
pull the other distal promoter enhancer
exons together. And through a mechanism
that use the four virus RNA
replication and processing, that this can
help to splice those two exons three and
10 together. So we have validated that using a
CRISPR deletion, as you can see here, even just by
deleting one of the repeat regions, you can reduce the
circRNA expression to only about 30%
left.
Okay, so
we have shown a lot of data that human,
if you knock down circRMST, the cell is pretty much dead in about seven
days. Very important in both cell culture and the xenograft
models. And
we further look at the genetic
knockout model, in which it's a triple
knockout model, TKO,
Rbp3 and P10. So this is a very interesting model
that in about four to six weeks, they will
develop adenocarcinoma. And starting from about eight weeks,
they will spontaneously transform from adenocarcinoma to
small cell, and then
many of them will die at 16 weeks of the tumor.
So we did a genetic knockout of RMST in the
background of
TKO. So firstly, you will see the tumor grows much slower, the mouse
live longer. But more importantly is that
those tumors, the small tumors that arise from the RMST
knockout, they stay at the adenoma stage.
So the knockout not only reduce the tumor growth, but
also arrest it or prevent it from neuroendocrine
transdifferentiation. So how does it do that?
So we did gene expression, knock down RMST.
The gene signature you will see is pretty much related to neuronal fate,
and one of the main target we identified is actually ASL1,
which is a major driver of a lineage transformation,
and driving the AESOP type of small cell lung cancer.
And
in almost every cell line model with neuroendocrine prostate cancer, small cell
lung cancer, when you knock down circRMST, you pretty much wipe out
ASL1 protein level. Okay. How does it do that?
So we did a
RNA probe to pull down circRMST and then look at what are
the proteins interacting with circRMST.
So we identified quite a number of
interacting proteins, including RNA processing,
DNA repair, stress granule. But what caught our eye
are the two transcription factors,
Nkx2.1 and SOX2. And because of those
two transcription factors are very key in lineage
transdifferentiation and in particular in
transcriptionally activating ASL1.
So they have both of them bind to the promoter regions of ASL1.
So in this case, if we knock down circRMST, you will see the
binding of both transcription factors decrease at
ASL1.
So when we knock down circRMST,
SOX2 protein does not change, but
Nkx2.1 protein is pretty much gone.
So those are the two transcription factors that interact
with this non-coding RNA. So if you knock down the interaction
RNA, Nkx2.1 protein goes down. So,
a number of years ago,
in neural progenitor cells,
it had been reported. At that time, you'd think
RMST is a linear gene, and it had been reported that in
neural progenitor cells, that
RMST and SOX2 interact. And
then RMST is actually helping SOX2 to
bind with the
promoter regions. So then we focused on understanding
how this interaction affect the
Nkx2.1 protein abundance, and we kind of
suspect it must be related toIts protein
stability, and it turns out to be true.
So NK2.1 is a relatively stable protein,
with a half-life around 17 hours. So if you
knock down circMST, you will reduce the protein half-life to
about five hours. So it's a pretty dramatic
reduction of the protein stability.
So how does it do that? So when we look at the binding
regions, so this is where they predict the RNA binding region with
NK2.1, and then downstream, about 10 amino acid.
This has a motif
called Hsp70
motif. So this is a very unique
chaperone-mediated autophagy mechanism that
specifically recognize, Hsp70
specifically recognize the proteins with this short five
amino acid, and then internalize to the lysosome
and then degrade the protein. And this Hsp70
binding site is only 10 amino acid away from where
the RNA binding domain. So we think that because the RNA
is about one KB long,
so that's a big molecule will block the interaction of
the Hsp70 protein degradation
complex. And it turns out to be true, when we knock out
Hsp70, you can pretty much 100% rescue the
protein degradation mediated by
circMST.
So that's not the end of the story of the mechanism.
So in collaboration with Chenghua, we originally wanted to use a technology
that he developed to study the
RMST secondary structure. So we think the structure is very important
for the interaction. So this is a chemical-based approach using catoxyl,
and the dendrimer to
label the RNAs that are in close proximity.
So that later on, you can use that to infer RNA secondary
structure. But it turns out that you can also using this
approach to identify RNA-RNA interaction, like different
RNA molecule interaction.
And to our surprise, we actually find about over
700 RNA transcript
or different RNA that interact with circMST, and
those are not random. So those 700
interacting RNAs are pretty much enriched in the
neural development and the nervous system development.
So a lot of things are
pointing to the function of circMST in neural.
So it's not only in cancer. And then, as actually turns
out, a number of years ago, as Arthur mentioned in previously,
that circMST expressed in early mouse
brain development, and in particular, in neural progenitor
cells. So, I would say,
whether circMST is really important in neuron development or in
brain function, so we did the whole body
genetic knockout mice, just knock out the promoter and the first
three exon regions of RMST.
So the RMST in mouse actually expressed in a
number of regions, though the most abundant region is
medial amygdala region. Some of the expression
in hippocampus. And then the student who
generated this genetic knockout mouse actually didn't
observe any phenotype. The mice are totally fine.
The lifespan is about 300 days,
same as the wild-type mice, and no obvious functional
defect.
It's quite disappointing at that time. He spent so much effort.
But then he left for Eli Lilly, and then we didn't
give up, and I said, "It must have something there because the expression is pretty
high." So another PhD student in the lab took it
over and did a behavior test because of its expression in brain,
and it become very interesting. So we did two tests.
The first is a fear test, as you know,
if you have ever seen a mouse in your basement, if you shout at it,
it'll freeze.
So it's fear testing, so it's a noise, and then the mice will
freeze, and it will measure the time that the mouse
freeze.
If it's freeze more, means it's more anxious. Okay.
So you will see here in the knockout mice,
it freeze a significant more, twice more than the wild-type
mice. And we did another test, which is a depression test.
So you hang the mice on their tail. So if they struggle, it
means they're normal. If they don't struggle that much, it means they're
depressed. So whatsoever, you can just hang there.
And you will also see that a very significant
low mobility in the knockout mice.
So that means those mice are actually somewhat depressed.
So it is very important and interesting
function of the circRNA,
not only in tumor, but also in normal physiological
development. So to summarize, we think the
circMST as a
functional circRNA regulates some neural
behavior,
emotional behaviors. So we're further validating
that.
And then in cancer, in particular, in the transformation from
adenocarcinoma to neuroendocrine
prostate cancer, it's very important in regulating or
controlling the transdifferentiation and also the growth and the
survival of the neuroendocrine
tumor. And mechanism-wise, we think it's interact with
transcription factors, but through very distinct mechanism with
SOX2, it's helping, it's bind to the promoter regions
or for SOX2, it's through
keeping it more stable.And then the interaction
with quite a large number of neuronal-related
genes and the cell cycle genes, we have some hint here.
Their function in sequestering them to P body and
stress granule. So those are something that we are
actively exploring in the lab.
So,
I've shown you there are a lot of circRNAs expressed in patient tumor, and some
of them are very important functional-wise, and are
they clinically useful? So one
important feature of a circRNA is actually because they're
covalently closed structure, they are resistant to
exonuclease degradation because most of the exonuclease
chop the RNA from the 3' prime end. The circRNA don't have a
free 3' prime end.
We have tested in patient tumors, as I mentioned.
In most of the cases, the circular form is less abundant
compared to the linear part, less than 5%, as it show here.
The red color is a distribution abundance of circRNA in
patient tumor,
and then the cyan color represent the linear
transcript. So if you look at the cell-free RNA,
and it's the opposite. The circRNA is more
abundant than their linear transcript.
So if you compare the ratio of
circRNA and the linear, and then
analyze the shift
from tumor to
plasma or to cell-free RNA, there's actually over 1,000-fold
increase of the ratio of circular versus their
linear counterpart. So we have some work in this area to
profile
circRNA in a cell-free RNA scenario.
And then this is one example, of course, we'll look at the circMST.
And in some cases of the neuroendocrine tumors,
in particular small cell cancer, we do see high
abundance of circMST in the plasma samples, but don't
see that in the healthy control plasma samples, but
we miss a lot.
So that means the sensitivity is not high.
So we're actively looking into that to combine that with
other biomarkers, but there is some hope here.
So the other
clinical utility is actually also based on its nature that's more stable
in blood. And then in both academia and in
industry, there are a lot of efforts to use this
circular form to develop or to deliver
mRNA
into human body or testing in preclinical
models.
So
you can deliver a linear mRNA, but you can also engineer
it into a circular form, but still has the
translation machineries or components there.
So this is my colleague, Bowen Li. His
lab did a lot of testing in this area.
And in cell line models, you will see that the circular form,
their expression is more long-lasting than
if you just use the linear
mRNA. But what is more exciting is actually in vivo, in
mice. So using the circular form delivered using
lipid nanoparticle, and then until 19 days, we can
still see some signal there
if you deliver in the circular form, while if you deliver in the
linear form, at day three, you pretty much see the signal is
gone. So it's provide a very powerful
delivering
strategies for mRNA.
So, the last piece I want to share with you is actually in some of the
circRNA, they can translate into protein.
Actually, this translation mechanism is very interesting.
So, in some ways, they will translate, and then when
it's past the back splicing site, it's
usually will form a different
reading frame compared to its parental gene, so it's very different,
generate different peptides than parental gene.
And in some cases, they can actually go on the reverse
strand. So because the circle, you can go from the 5' to 3' prime
end, it also can go from 3' to 5' prime end.
So it's generate a complete and different
peptide. And in other cases, when they
bypass the back splicing site, if they don't
meet a stop codon, they will keep going and then
will bypass again. In other cases, it will keep going if there is no
stop codon
in that design. And in the GFP experiment
design, you actually can see a large aggregate of GFP
generated from a very small circRNA.
So,
because of the circRNA, they are very tissue and cancer
subtype specific. They're actually
ideal for antigen discovery and
cancer vaccine design.
So in our lab, we have recently developed a low
input immunopeptidome approach with a purpose to
identify immunopeptide as presented
at the surface of tumor cells.
So in this case,
we identified in those models about
4,500 immunopeptide that are presented on the surface
of the tumor cells.And we identified about 80
of them are actually generated from circRNA.
It's not a big number, but because the circRNA are cancer type
specific, usually cancer type specific, they are
probably more ideal for cancer vaccine design.
And out of those
80, majority of them are coming from the kind of canonic
splicing or translation from five to three prime end, but
you do see about 12 of them are actually only reversed
translation, and about 24 of them are actually coming from those
so-called rolling circle translation.
So those provide us kind of additional sources to
look at the
immunopeptide
presenting on tumor cells and for cancer vaccine design.
So the last slide I want to share with you from high level some of
the efforts that we have done at Princess Margaret and the University Health
Network,
RM-SEN initiative we launched in early
2023. So we basically have three platforms.
So the first being to identify therapeutic targets using
the approach that I have just
mentioned to you. And then we have a team using AI-based
approach to design either siRNA, antisense oligo,
or, in the case of cancer vaccine, the mRNA.
And together with my colleague,
Bowen Li and Gang Zhen, we're developing
new delivering platform,
new formulations of lipid nanoparticle for tissue and
organ specific delivery. We have a core facility with a
small team focused on preclinical,
lipid nanoparticle, and mRNA production
for preclinical testing. And we have partnered with other
academic cores and institute across Canada and
also industries to
develop
RNA-based therapy.
Okay. So with that, I'll finish my presentation and I
want to make a few acknowledgments.
So first, I would like to thank my PhD supervisor, Dr.
Yunxin Chen,
for opening the door of non-coding RNA, which
now is really to the bottom of my heart.
And for Miles and Shirley,
not only for
introducing me to the cancer epigenetic field, but for
the continued support that they have provided me
over the years. And even today, they're in the audience to
support me. And I strongly believe in team science.
And in over the
past decade or so, I had the luck to work with
so many wonderful collaborators, many of those I have kept
the collaboration for more than 10 years.
I list some of them. I'm sure I missed many of
them. And for the funding agencies and then my
current and
past lab members, it's just a blast to work together with so
many
young and bright and talented
next generation of scientists. And last but
not least,
my family, my wife,
my parents, my in-laws, and my sister for their love and
unwavering support. And for my
pre-teenager and teenager kids,
who
believe when I'm not at home, I'm doing the great thing for the rest of
the world.
Okay, with that, I would like to thank you for your attention.
Thank you so much. So we have time for
questions.
Very nice talk. Congratulations for your award.
I have a question about, is this circular RNA and linear
mRNA like interchangeable or like in the
tumors or in the normal cells, and if they have different frequency for
different disease?
Yeah, that's a great question. So I think if what you are referring to is actually
the circular and the linear ratio, right?
So actually, in different tissue type, we do see the
circular and linear ratio changes quite a lot.
But I think this is kind of an understudied area
in terms of biomarker discovery and then also
their functional annotation. So when we look at the biomarker, we
just look at the abundance, but actually, the ratio matters quite a lot.
That's a great question. And Miles.
Hans, a beautiful talk. So is there any evidence that these circular RNAs
can replicate? So,
hepatitis delta virus is a circular RNA, and there are
other circular RNA viroids. I just wonder, any evidence that there's
replication of any of these circles?
That's a great question.
I haven't thought about it. Yeah. I
need to think about it, yeah. So I feel sorry for Miles because this is
the talk he probably heard
three times in a row in the last nine months or so.
I think it's more frequent than my
postdoc lab meeting.
And still mentors find ways to ask you questions-
Right
... and challenge your thought.
Thank you, Miles.
Hi. I was just wondering how different is human and
mouse RMST?
And then is the interactome, how similar or different is it?
You mean human and mice?
Yeah.
Yeah. That's a great question. So I think from sequence-wise, it's very
conserved. Even structure-wise, it's very conserved.
But I point out in the difference in human and mice is the last
exon.
In mouse, we saw a pretty strong signal of
expression, but in human, we don't see it.
So we don't see whether there are any difference.
So in terms of interaction with the proteins, I think
interacting with SOX2 has been
shown previously in mice. So we're in the process of
testing other things, but I believe because their target
genes are conserved, I think the interaction proteins are likely
conserved as well. Thank you very much.
All right. So if there are no further questions, let's
congratulate Dr. He again.
And thank you everyone-
Thank you
... for joining us in this session.
Great job